R
GUN REFORM BILL THAT LOGICAL
REPORTEDLY, THEY SAY, WELL,
DEFINITELY WILL CREATE MORE RED
FLAG LAWS IN WHAT OPPONENTS SAY
IS JUST THE LATEST STEP TOWARDS
ENACTING MORE RESTRICTIONS ON
LAW ABIDING AMERICAN GUN OWNERS.
THE BILL WILL DO NOTHING WHO
PREVENT FUTURE SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
THIS IS A CLASSIC CASE OF FEEL
GOODISM, SYMBOLISM OVER
SUBSTANCE AND I EXPECT AS MUCH
FROM THE DEMOCRATS, BUT IT'S THE
REPUBLICANS I HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH HERE.
THEY'RE GOING TO SPIN THIS.
THIS BILL'S GOING TO BE FOCUSED
ON MENTAL HEALTH WHO'S AGAINST
PEOPLE WHO NEED MENTAL HEALTH
HELP.
AND THEY'RE TRYING TO AS I KNOW
THE EXCUSE ON THE RED FLAG LAW.
IT CAN ONLY BE TEMPORARY YOU
MIGHT HAVE A CHANCE TO LIFT IT
LATER.
AND WHEN THE NEXT SCHOOL
SHOOTING HAPPENS WITH A
DIFFERENT WEAPON, WHAT ARE THEY
GOING DO THEN?
HOW ABOUT WE GIVE EVERY SCHOOL
IN AMERICA UNDERCOVERED ARMED,
TRAINED, RETIRED POLICE OFFICERS
AND MILITARY, HAVE ONE WAY IN
THE SCHOOL, ONE WAY OUT,
EMERGENCY PLAN GOD FORBID
THERE'S A FIRE, HAVE EVERY KID
GO THROUGH A METAL DETECTOR,
SAME PROTECTION WE GIVE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AND HOLLYWOOD STARS
THAT HAVE ALL THE SECURITY IN
THE WORLD THAT ARE ARMED.
ONE OF THE FEW SENATORS TALKING
SENSE ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE IS
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ.
I'LL BE HONEST SENATOR, YOU
KNOW, I LISTENED TO YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICANS.
IT'S BEYOND DISAPPOINTING THAT
THEY ARE INVOLVED, WE'LL PUT
THEIR NAMES UP ON THE SCREEN,
BECAUSE THIS ISN'T GOING TO
WORK.
LET'S SAY -- TELL ME HOW THIS IS
GOING TO PREVENT THE NEXT SCHOOL
SHOOTING.
YOUR BILL WITH THE SENATOR WOULD
GO A LONG WAY TO DOING THAT.
NONE OF THEM ARE DOING A THING
TO PROTECT ANY KID IN ANY SCHOOL
I SEE.
>> SEAN, I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND TRAGICALLY WE'VE SEEN THE
SAME PATTERN PLAY OUT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
EVERY TIME THERE IS A HORRIFIC
MASS MURDER AND THERE HAVE BEEN
FAR TOO MANY OF THEM.
I WAS IN UVALDE THE DAY AFTER
THAT HORRIFIC ATTACK WHEN THAT
PSYCHOPATH MURDERED 19 CHILDREN
AND TWO TEACHERS AND IT IS
HORRIFIC.
WE NEED TO STOP THEM.
BUT INSTANTANEOUSLY, WHEN
THERE'S A CRIMINAL ATTACK, A
MASS MURDER, WE HAVE A DEBATE
IN, WA TON AND THERE ARE TWO
APPROACHES.
ONE APPROACH IS TARGET THE BAD
GUYS, TARGET THE CRIMINALS,
TARGET THE VIOLENT FELONS AND
THOSE WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WHO TRY TO ILLEGALLY BUY
FIREARMS, PROSECUTE THEM PUT
THEM IN JAIL GET THEM OFF THE
STREET AND KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND
THAT INCLUDES PROTECTING
VULNERABLE PLACES LIKE SCHOOLS
AND CHURCHES WITH POLICE
OFFICERS.
THAT'S AN APPROACH THAT, WOULD.
THAT'S AN APPROACH THAT MAKES
SENSE.
THE OTHER APPROACH, THE APPROACH
OF THE DEMOCRATS IS TO TRY TO
TAKE AWAY FIREARMS FROM LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS.
TO TRY TO GO AFTER THE SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS.
AND THAT APPROACH IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BUT IT ALSO
DOESN'T WORK.
IT'S COMPLETELY INEFFECTIVE IN
STOPPING VIOLENT CRIME.
AND SO THIS PARTICULAR BILL THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE VOTING ON THIS
WEEK I THINK IS MISGUIDED.
I THINK IT'S A MISTAKE.
YOU MENTIONED THE RED FLAG LAWS.
THOSE RED FLAG LAWS PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DISARM LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS IN MANY STATES
WITH A VERY LOW STANDARD OF
PROOF WITH LITTLE OR NO DUE
PROCESS PROTECTION, AND I THINK
THAT IS NOT GOING TO PREVENT
VIOLENT CRIME BUT IT IS GOING TO
MAKE PEOPLE MORE VULNERABLE AND
LESS ABLE TO DEFEND THEIR HOMES
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
JUST TODAY I INTRODUCED
LEGISLATION.
>> Sean: YES, SIR.
>> WITH JOHN BARRASSO CALLED THE
CRUISE BARRASSO LEGISLATION, AND
IT'S FOCUSED ON STOPPING VIOLENT
CRIME, FOCUSED ON FUNDING
PROSECUTORS THAT IF YOU THE
COMMIT A CRIME WITH A GUN YOU'RE
PRODUCT AND SENT TO PRISON.
IF YOU TRY TO ILLEGALLY BUY A
GUN AS A FELON OR FUGITIVE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PROSECUTED
AND SENT TO FEDERAL PRISON AND
THIS BILL PROVIDES $36 BILLION
FOR FUNDING OVER TEN YEARS FOR
POLICE OFFICERS, ARMED POLICE
OFFICERS IN SCHOOLS THAT DOUBLES
THE NUMBER OF POLICE OFFICERS IN
SCHOOLS, IT PROVIDES $10 BILLION
IN FUNDING FOR MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS.
SO IF YOU HAVE A KID THAT HAS
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES YOU
STOP HIM EARLY BEFORE HE COMMITS
THE CRIME.
THIS IS THE APPROACH THAT MAKES
SENSE.
AND CRITICALLY, MY LEGISLATION,
CRUZ BARRASSO, DOESN'T INFRINGE
IN ANY WAY ON THE SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS.
IT'S TARGETED AT THE BAD GUYS
AND IT KEEPS YOU AND ME AND THE
REST OF US SAFE.
>> Tucker: I HOPE PEOPLE CALL
THEIR SENATORS.
WE PUT THE REPUBLICAN NAMES ON
THE SCREEN, TO LET THEM KNOW YOU
DON'T SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION.
>> SO WE HAVE THIS JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE WITH THE PREDETERMINED
OUTCOME FROM THE GET GO, TO
BLUDGEON DONALD TRUMP.
THEY HAVE SWORN TESTIMONY, UNDER
OATH, THAT DONALD TRUMP
AUTHORIZED, TWO DAYS BEFORE
JANUARY 6TH, UP TO 20,000 TROOPS
BE CALLED IN.
NOW, THAT'S REQUIRED BY LAW.
THEN THE JURISDICTION AT THAT
POINT GOES TO NANCY PELOSI,
MURIEL BOWSER, THE MAYOR OF DC.
THE MAYOR OF DC, IN WRITING,
DECLINED TO CALL UP THE TROOPS
ON, WE KNOW, THREE DAYS BEFORE
THE 6TH, CAPITOL POLICE CHIEF,
BASED ON NEW INTELLIGENCE, HE
STARTED REQUESTING THE GUARD
TROOPS BE CALLED UP, AND HE WAS
DENIED.
WHY HAVEN'T THEY LOOKEDED INTO
WHY THEY DID NOT TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY KNOWING WE CAME OFF A
SUMMER OF 574 RIOTS.
BY THE WAY, WHERE'S THE
COMMITTEE INVESTING THAT?
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: AND NOW WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE DIRECT THREATS.
WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO GET A
DECISION ON ROE v WADE THIS
WEEK.
IF WE GET THAT DECISION THIS
WEEK, THERE ARE GROUPS THAT ARE
CALLING FOR PEOPLE TO RIOT.
>> YES.
>> Sean: WE REPORTED ON IT LAST
NIGHT.
WHAT IS JOE BIDEN, WHAT ARE
THESE BIG CITIES DOING TO
PROTECT PEOPLE IN LIGHT OF A
THREAT THAT WE NOW KNOW IS
PUBLIC?
>> WELL, LET ME START WITH WHERE
YOU ENDED, WHICH IS, I THINK,
THE SUPREME COURT IN THE NEXT
WEEK IS GOING TO ISSUE ITS
DECISION.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO OVERTURN
ROE v WADE.
THAT'S THE RIGHT DECISION.
>> Sean: DOESN'T THEIR SESSION
END THIS WEEK?
>> THEY COULD DO IT NEXT WEEK.
SO IT COULD BE TOMORROW, IT
COULD BE NEXT WEEK.
WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE WHEN THE
OPINION WILL ISSUE.
BUT IT'S SOON.
IT'S WITHIN THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
THAT'S THE RIGHT DECISION, THAT
WILL RETURN THE QUESTION OF
ABORTION TO THE ELECTED
LEGISLATURE, THAT'S WHERE THE
CONSTITUTION LEFT IT.
THAT'S WHERE IT BELONGS.
BUT I THINK THE RESPONSE IS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID, WHICH IS
THE ORGANIZED LEFT, THEY'RE
GOING TO ENGAGE IN RYE YACHTS,
THEY'RE GOING TO ENGAGE IN
VIOLENCE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A REPRISE, I
FEAR, OF THE BLACK LIVES MATTER
AND THE ANTIFA RIOTS WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO USE
POLITICAL VIOLENCE TO ADVANCE
THEIR ENDS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE NEEDS TO STEP IN AND
STOP THEM.
I HALF WAY EXPECT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO BE RIOTING ALONGSIDE
THEM BECAUSE THIS DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS BEEN SO POLITICIZED.
NOW, YOU MENTIONED IN THE FIRST
PART OF YOUR QUESTION THE
JANUARY 6TH SO-CALLED SELECT
COMMITTEE HEARING.
THIS THING IS A JOKE.
THIS IS NOT A CONGRESSIONAL
HEARING.
SO A CONGRESSIONAL HEARING IS
DESIGNED TO BE A FACT FINDING
MISSION.
YOU HAVE OPPOSING SIDES.
THIS IS A POLITICAL DEMOCRATIC
CAMPAIGN COMMERCIAL.
AND LET ME JUST ASK YOU THIS
QUESTION.
WHAT WOULD YOU THINK IF YOU HAD
A CRIMINAL TRIAL AND THE JUDGE
SAID, OKAY, WE'RE ONLY GOING TO
ALLOW THE PROSECUTEOR TO SPEAK.
ONLY THE PROSECUTOR CAN CALL
WITNESSES, THE DEFENSE DOESN'T
GET TO CROSS-EXAMINATION THOSE
WITNESSES AND WE'RE ONLY GOING
TO PRESENT ONE SIDE OF THE
STORY.
THAT'S WHAT NANCY PELOSI IS
DOING, IT'S A CAMPAIGN
COMMERCIAL.
>> Sean: IF YOU WANT TO PREVENT
IT FROM HAPPENING AGAIN, YOU
PROBABLY SHOULD LOOK INTO THE
QUESTION AS WHY THEY DIDN'T CALL
UP THE TROOPS.
>> YEAH.
>> Sean: THAT THE GUY THAT
THEY'RE CLAIMING WANTED THIS TO
HAPPEN AUTHORIZED.
BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOU